então a primeira questão que eu quero
trazer aqui para a gente é quem eu
confesso que eu levei 15 6 anos com a
terapeuta para tentar entender quem eu
sou e não consegui entender exatamente
quem eu sou ainda mas a traçando um
pouquinho as coisas que eu passei
pianista eu estudei sete anos pelo
clássico até que um dia tá fazendo o
conserto
a professora me diz cara se errar que
encerra a obra estava tocando beethoven
esquecida obra completamente e começa a
improvisar e aí tomei uma uma vaia
violenta e achei que não era hora pra
mim o que você toca guitarra foram 12
anos de guitarra foi interessante foi
que algumas bandas mas também não rolou
paixão acabou o trabalho começa a
trabalhar com estratégia achei
interessante e achei um processo mais
mais bem organizado
virei produtor musical entrei na
faculdade de relações públicas
achei interessante o caráter generalista
da faculdade mas eu ficava mais tempo
matando aula e nos estúdios com os
publicitários do que propriamente na
cadeira de rp até aqui há dez anos atrás
eu me tornei eu eu na verdade não tem
uma empresa que é diferente do
empresário e hoje eu me considero
será que dá pra dizer isso um software
que é isso eu fiz eu pensei uma
derivação na verdade de design thinking
porque eu trabalho há 15 anos com
publicidade
fiz muitas trilhas pra gente aqui gente
de fora do brasil também mas eu chego
momento para pessoas inquietas como eu
que o ciclo fecha não quer que sua
bagagem que aproveitar essa bagagem mas
trazer coisas novas
e uma e uma curiosidade e um processo
que eu sempre tive nos meus trabalhos na
verdade eu trago pro hoje é cada vez
mais é um aprendizado de saber escutar
as pessoas ouvem muito mas se falou
muito aqui de a dificuldade de saber
escutar um briefing publicitário por
exemplo isso é muito recorrente nós
mesmos nós nesse dia a dia acaba
passando despercebido a necessidade de
entender o que o outro quer isso é tão
pleno é tão profundo não é só um
briefing nosso target é entender
exatamente expectativa de um criativo
que passou dos três madrugadas criando
aquilo a entender a expectativa da
agência o cliente é entender a
expectativa daquele cliente o seu
público
aí sim depois que eu entendo
para onde eu vou eu tenho me dedico a
criar para então eu entender quais
pessoas eu preciso quais disciplinas vão
fazer parte desse contexto para eu
conseguir entregar algo concreto e uma
coisa que vale muito pra mim hoje cada
vez mais com essa ferramenta de saltinho
quem é esse viés multidisciplinar de dar
contra pólos com psicólogos com artesãos
com um fim com a partir de advogados
também hoje pelo projeto agora pouco
também envolvendo advogado foi muito
interessante a partir de cessão de
direito ou seja é interessante esse
caráter multifacetado é o que eu faço eu
saiba não vier de reprodutor musical
reprodutor sonoro e entrou num numa
esfera de conectar a marca de pessoas
através do som de idéias e experiências
sonoras como é que como é que se faz
isso como que na prática a a gente
consegue comprovar que essa idéia de são
tim que parece um pouco né maluca
na prática ela consegue funcionar ano
passado um shopping um grande shopping
do sul do brasil chamou pra colocar
música no mall
e eu sinceramente perguntei pra quê
por que vocês querem colocar a música no
mall ea minha surpresa que não sei não
sabiam
eu não sei porque todas as empresas
colocam música no mall e nós queremos
colocar música bom eu provoquei eles
como que a gente pode transcender então
se esse caráter do consumo e agregar
algo de valor para as pessoas através do
som de um processo de escuta em um livro
e esse livro me movimentou o que me
tornei hoje do morro e chefe afinação do
mundo e ele traz esse conceito de
paisagem sonora uma forma magnífica
traçando um paralelo na verdade entre a
evolução dos grandes centros
e essa involução sonora ou seja a gente
vive cada vez mais no meio ou entorno em
volta de ruído não se ter uma noção
nesse exato momento desde sua
apresentação você estão escutando uma
freqüência média grave
levanta a mão quem está prestando
atenção nisso agora pode parar
o mais interessante é que shoppings
lojas escritórios e pedem mais música e
eu pergunto cara mas como funciona o
ambiente de vocês elementos musicais são
ruído voz como que os colaboradores de
vocês clientes e colaboradores vocês se
manifesta através da voz e música
será que é preciso mais música mais som
pra apavorar um pouquinho mais vocês aí
eu quero mostrar a diferença entre uma
faixa e outra de ruído
o ruído aqui na verdade não cresce 5
desse 10
depois mais seis pés ele exponencial não
pode tocar 60 decibéis para mim por
favor
ok agora mais ruído pouquinho
agora dez vezes mais ruído que a gente
fez a minha curiosidade era como que
funciona o ruído de fundo do shopping já
não é exacerbado enquanto ruídos e
provoca naquele espaço onde pessoas
convivem por muito tempo às vezes
principalmente funcionários e
colaboradores
nós mapeamos não está passando e passar
essa lei nós mapeamos todo o shopping ea
média de ruído encontrada foi 71
decibéis com picos de 82 pontos 7 o
pedido inicial era eu quero música ou
seja eu quero botar mais som e aí uma
curiosidade que o que eu tava que eu
tive é imagina se eu registrasse uma
imagem e do som dela não fez uma imagem
sonora
eu fotografei esse local e gravei o som
das 10 horas pode trocar o primeiro
arquivo favor
agora o som real do carrinho de
reciclagem deles pode tocar fogo não
pode tomar pode tomar posse o primeiro
arquivo
o foco segundo
o 25 carrinhos diferente do shopping diz
um deles
essa música é proveniente dessa lógica
pode tocar
e um arquivo
até o meio dia
em contrapartida o shopping tinha
ambientes mais silenciosos
só que por exemplo pode tocar o player
do rádio favor do rádio
uma pesquisa da europa mostrou que esse
som e ao invés de potencializar
segurança e menor consumo
a sensação das pessoas é que algo pode
acontecer aqui marido
a minha tendência é se afastar dessa
pessoa mas para maquinário vez você se
identificam esse som maquinário
esse som e gravado aqui aqui e aqui
atrás é uma máquina
sorvetes de uma empresa muito famosa
você pode ver o nome aqui mas né
o emmy é o longo dela
ok o mais interessante gente assim como
vocês não estavam ouvindo aquele ruído
inicial
a gente tá vivendo no período de
poluição sonora
eu comecei até um tempo atrás com como
os amigos e eu disse que se eu tenho uma
meta de sustentabilidade é reduzir a
poluição sonora
talvez começando por porto alegre brasil
lá fora
sei lá pode passar que se tornam o de
novo carro nã outra questão que andava
preocupado é um ambiente de tanto ruído
mais do que clientes que freqüentam em
30 minutos até uma hora duas horas enfim
tem essas as chapas das consumidoras
frenéticas como que colaborar com que
colaboradores que trabalham de 6 a 8
horas às vezes ininterrupta nesse espaço
são impactadas por esse brasil mostrará
a idosa é muito interessante porque os
outros trabalhos estão acontecendo os
clientes muié sempre foco em clientes ou
seja consumidores shoppers né mais
cliente quer mais clientes ok mas como é
que consegue trazer primeiro mapa um bem
estar para os seus colaboradores para
que a partir disso eles reverberem isso
as suas próprias clientes e isso foi o
mais interessante do projeto nós
entrevistamos com uma fonoaudióloga
todos os colaboradores que têm contato
com os clientes
eu tinha curiosidade eu peguei o mapa de
ruído e pedir o mapa de localização de
colaboradores fixos quiosques de
estacionamento
eu peguei essas informações e cruzei
quando cruzei lembrei conta que essas
pessoas estavam quase que exatamente
embaixo da zona sul idosas conversando
com elas e é muito interessante a
disparidade que existe entre os manuais
e o que acontece na prática
nós somos pessoas na prática
o manual não acontece de fato eu estou
no meio do do processo o idoso eu tenho
que comunicar com o cliente como eu faço
na frente dessas pessoas a maioria são
meninas
além de descartar o idoso existe um
vidro de oito milímetros
sem razão nenhuma o que acontece é que
elas me comentaram que mais do que
cobrar o tíquete de estacionamento
elas dão informações sobre localização
de lojas promoções e eventos
imagina o esforço dessas pessoas para se
comunicar elas têm que repetir de duas a
três vezes a mesma coisa só que na
terceira estão errando
meu dna desse cliente a sofisticação
será que uma pessoa berrando com o disco
sofisticação transcendendo o caráter
comercial eo bem estar das pessoas
a síntese na verdade é que muitas marcas
trazem esse viés de sofisticação o
aspecto visual o caráter muito forte
conta pilares e direcionadores só que o
som há uma miopia sonora e isso acontece
com todos nós seja no carro com a janela
aberta seja o nosso escritório seja num
supermercado seja um shopping center
o insight
na verdade dividiu nessas três frentes
voz rui de música
construímos manuais mas de novo eu
trouxe os próprios colaboradores para
montar esse manual fazendo com que essas
regras fosse benéficas primeiro pra eles
construímos um projeto piloto ea
primeira pergunta é como escolher um
certo na hora certa
a minha preocupação é como trazer
bem-estar primeiros colaboradores e
depois travessa reverbera isso o dna da
marca dos clientes
criamos muito sonoros
a cada faixa de horário identificando-se
tinha um viés de lexi ou seja queria
relaxar ou queria citar essas pessoas ea
questão chave é o seguinte
fundamentalmente como a música o som de
desculpa não está presente na no mental
de empresários principalmente a maioria
dos shoppings ou de empresas do brasil
não possui a culpa nenhuma
então imagina que está no restaurante e
tem eu estou sóbrio e só que tem um
grupo ao lado que não está sob essas
pessoas começam a falar mais alto
automaticamente para eu me tornar mais
inteligível com a pessoa que eu tô
conversando eu vou levar o meu tom de
voz e assim acontece em escala
quando não tenho nenhum tratamento
acústico o som reflete sem parar e sobe
então eu consigo tratar os sons dos a
dos carrinhos ou sons provenientes do
shopping consigo eu consigo regular o
som da avenida das lojas consigo consigo
para a regular o som proveniente das
provenientes das pessoas não é que eu
faço isso trabalhamos com a organização
conta dourado aqui
a organização do tipo de caixa correto
para esse tipo de cenário na sacada foi
aqui e colocamos um microfone
produzimos um software específico pra
quê 10 horas da manhã eu tenho
multipista eu tenho instrumentos
diferentes tocando ao mesmo tempo 11
horas o ruído sobe e paulatinamente o
software vai retirando instrumentos que
sejam conflitantes com a faixa de
freqüência que está acontecendo ali de
ruído principalmente para causar mais
bem estar das pessoas que trabalham ali
pra fechar eu fiz esse fechamento hoje
gente porque eu achei a palestras muito
interessantes e eu estava repensando
essa questão de que o foco é conectar
marcas e pessoas através do som mas ao
final do projeto tô indo pra moscou
segunda-feira que está no final na final
de um evento super importante o upgrade
awards vai acontecer dia 28 no ano que
vem e tapera um reconhecimento
internacional mas acho mais interessante
foi o retorno que eu tive das pessoas
que trabalham lá e esse retorno foi tão
gratificante pessoas agradecendo
colaboradores seguranças que o som mais
agradável o ambiente mais agradável
eu acho que o meu grande foco na verdade
é promover o bem através de idéias
experiências sonoras
obrigado